[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake on
super excited to be talking about
spiritual awakening through art we have
Samantha Stein joining us on the show
hello hi thank you for having me and
hide all of you thank you so much for
coming on really appreciate it very
excited for the show we was it the first
time that we met at Lisa's birthday may
have been okay I think that might have
been the first time and then again I
believe seal foundations the twelve
screening which was great and also
Samantha Stein is a spiritual artist for
her bio that's it
nothing else super shortens to say you
can find the links in the bio the load
of the Instagram the Twitter as well as
the website
all right let's as we will be talking
about all of these beautiful pieces of
art throughout the show let's start
things off with what are your thoughts
on the direction of our world I think we
live in very interesting times and we
have more agency than ever to to push
the world in a positive or a negative
direction or to choose how we feel that
direction feels to us so it's really
interesting today as our environments
become increasingly immersive that at
the same exact time we're seeing you
know billion dollar valuations for
mindfulness apps and so I think that
begs the question why is that happening
and why now and I think the reason is is
Darwin says the thing that makes us most
fit for survival is activity and in
these highly immersive environments were
so much of what our environment exists
to do is manipulate us are by our
feedback our responses of things what
creates the greatest adaptive traits
perhaps is the ability to control our
minds
and our biofeedback to these responses
of environmental influence so it's crazy
times I think the direction can be good
when we really use mindfulness practices
to feel like we're interconnected with
all living beings and with one another
so we feel that residence and we can be
more collaborative than ever which is
when historically we see Renaissance I
think it can also create sort of this
idea that oh if the world doesn't feel
good to you that's your fault like you
should be meditating more than all of a
sudden everything will feel fine and
dandy which isn't the case and I think
there's there's also a side of it that's
quite problematic to create this
narrative that if it starts with
controlling your inner world to
influence your outer world that all of
the responsibility is on you when really
that's only part of the picture and it's
a collective effort to create the world
we want to see and I think as always we
have all of the tools available to
create a beautiful future and a
beautiful here and now where do you
think things went wrong along the
journey
well the civilization experiments that
have occurred so there's different ways
to examine cultures and to examine
societies I think one paradigm that I've
been thinking about a lot lately and I
think many of us has have as we're
hearing all these headlines capitalism
is dead capitalism is over like
Millennials fake capitalism whatever it
is we've seen like hundreds of
iterations now I think what these are
really saying is that there's there's
two cultural paradigms that maybe we're
most familiar with which are a Dominator
paradigm where there's always
hierarchical power and there it's it's
fairly zero-sum I mean I think we had
the client patron relationships more in
the past and now it's shifted more to
completely a zero-sum model and
Dominator cultures which is why we're
seeing you know the environment just
totally depleted with disregard and then
you also have collaborative environments
where you see that people are working
together in order
to share resources and create a sense of
abundance and I think when we shift to
Dominator cultures and paradigms and we
take that to its extreme which another
way to think about it is like a
hedonistic extreme the result is that
we've taken a wrong term and there's
many many people suffering as a result
of that not just people you know plants
animals earth is suffering many of the
indigenous cultures point at our
disconnection from source from nature
being the reason why we have so many of
the ailments in our world do you align
yourself with that feeling yeah I think
it's interesting that people can feel
disconnected from their environments I
mean I certainly feel that many times
right that I'm I'm disconnected from
groups of people or cultures or plants
or animals but then when you really sit
and think about evolution we're actually
related to all of these things like
these are these are by extension on a
macro scale relatives yeah and that's
really so different so far back we want
to go and I think when you you really
take a moment to think about what that
means and think about the
interconnectedness it points out a
really good point about where we've also
gone wrong is where we've allowed
abstractions to mask the interdependence
of all things
the interdependence of all things is
something that we have the ability to
tap into on a moment-to-moment basis and
we also have went and as far as to say
that you can keep one foot in the world
of everything's connected and one foot
in the world of kind of like what's
happening in the 3d physical reality ego
stuff just so that you can in a way try
and co-create that future of the
triangle moving to the circle the
hierarchy moving to the decentralized
infrastructure you said so many things
we find ourselves at this moment now
some people say we went off of the DAO
we went off of the path other people say
that no this is the path it's supposed
to be this damn hard that's the point of
the game for it to be this hard and you
said that you know you probably one of
the most familiar ways of you of viewing
what's going on in the world now is this
these 1 billion dollar-plus
evaluations of mindfulness technology
companies everything from the neuro
technology like the brain sensing
headband companies like Meuse we've had
area on the show from her all the way to
the calm app for for meditation or
headspace so is this a is this a first
order or first principle solution to
what we need or is there something
that's even deeper in our roots that is
missing from our spiritual connection
all that is or is that a stepping stone
to get there I think it's important when
we think about consciousness technology
which is going to be a bigger and bigger
topic and it's going to be something we
see more and more venture capital flood
into that like all technology it's a
tool and all tools can be used for good
or bad and what I mean by that is that
they can all be used to either serve
humanity or harm humanity actually maybe
create more extreme domination
I mean if you you push sort of that mind
experiment to extreme where we could
invest in consciousness technology and
tools for mind control of populations to
subdue people and create really extreme
hierarchies so they can be used to bring
people and very much closer to a sense
of of deep compassion and
interconnectedness with all things and
they can be used to push them apart I
think when we think about the mind and
consciousness and meditation and the
benefits we got from it we often think
about there's actually this cartoon that
I think sums it up perfectly we think
about how it can be a tool for sometimes
creating a calm inner world or sometimes
we think about is like this makes me the
most productive best version of myself
and that latter version I think we're
seeing more and more people tap into and
my concern there is there's this great
cartoon I saw where it's a monk sitting
and meditating and then a guy in a suit
who's like oh you know good job it looks
like he's you know going to do some big
important meeting or something and what
his bubble says is I meditate eight
minutes a day so I can feel like I'm on
top of the world and the monkeys sitting
there on the ground his legs crossed
looks at him and says if you meditated
an hour a day you wouldn't need to yeah
yeah that's a good one yeah
so I think these tools are tools that
can be used for good and bad I don't
think that I think the idea of
short-circuiting feelings of that
deepened compassion and
interconnectedness could be a positive
thing I think it can all these things
can also be used in therapeutic context
to heal people which is really really
interesting yeah and the advances in
neuroscience they're quite promising
there's a lot of people suffering from
things like addiction or PTSD and these
tools are not just about you know a
spiritual awakening but they're also
have incredible applications for well
how could you use them in medical
context instead of using pharmacological
interventions yep
it's overall a positive thing but
something like any new technology or
tool that you have to be mindful of how
it's being used and safeguarded so that
it's used in a way to support humanity I
like that yeah safeguard the new tool
deployments so that they can be used to
as benevolent yeah yeah additions it's a
humanity I like that a lot okay
and this will continue coming up
throughout our conversation so let's
jump into the art we have this beautiful
piece right here I want to know as you
explained you know this piece is called
heart resonance
yeah and as you explain what your art is
how did you get interested in making art
for me I needed it was actually became
something that just felt like I was
meditating a lot and it as an extension
of that when I was creating out I
realized that I was getting into the
same sort of people what people describe
as a flow state where just like I would
be working on a piece and hours and
hours could pass and I just felt like a
complete flow and full of just joy and
contentment and just deeply present and
exactly what I was doing in that moment
and there's not many things in life I
had experienced that had given me that
same sort of feeling and so I mean my
parents actually both met in art school
and both started their careers as
artists but as a reaction to that I
think in many ways when I was younger I
wasn't very interested in art I was
interested in photography and even as a
child won some awards for photographs I
had taken but painting or oil pastels or
drawing or watercolors or painting these
other mediums I used today I hadn't
really taken an interest in at that time
so it was more more recently especially
within the last year that I started
getting especially interested in
painting as I have medium and today I'll
share a bunch of my paintings with you
Wow and then what's the heart resonance
I loved the we'll get to another one
that I actually ended up just adoring a
lot and this actually has it carries the
same style as the other one what is this
how does this make you feel when you
look at it Ron how does it make you feel
it reminds me of my ex-wife colors are
what her bridesmaids wore hmm it's a
lovely piece Ellen how does it make you
feel and thank you for sharing
so funny this is like a lot of a lot of
your art to me is about creation and I
think to me really good art is about
like origins or source and in like
immediately and what came to me when I
was observing the other piece of art
that has this very very similar style to
it was that we are nerve endings of God
yeah you know and so to me it's like
these are all of the different
expressions all the different nerve
endings of source that are then out
experiencing itself and then that's how
we kind of get the interconnectedness
and
yeah and then we become aware that we
are that and then that's when like
mother like realizing itself and then we
kind of like go back to like ourselves
and that's what it sort of this to me
what else what about yeah what about you
that's beautiful so I want my art to
make people feel connected to their
spirituality or make them feel like
there's things they want to seek out in
question in terms of that a feeling
interconnected to all living beings and
feeling a deepened sense of compassion
for the world and for everything around
them you know people keep talking about
going to space I really enjoy trust real
life so this is mostly a commentary on
terrestrial life how and this art this
arts meant for you to ask yourself
questions about your own spirituality
and also think terrestrial please
thinking about like yes there's life
beyond Earth but staying connected to
humanity and is extension of that all
living things as well so this is heart
resonance I've created other pieces
which we'll take a look at order a
similar theme where they're meant to
make you have to focus the eye because
there's a lot of movement in them
through the gradient quality yeah
and I'm intentionally doing that because
I want you to feel a bit disoriented and
feel like well what feels calming and
comfortable and that's why you have red
dots complemented by my blue and it's
heart resonance because whereas my other
pieces the different phases are shaped
like slightly different variations and
directions which feels like there's a
lot of movement and forces the eye to
study more quickly with this women so
you can look at it and then slowly study
in on different focal points and it's
the feeling I have when and I hope many
of you have or are looking for you know
found time and time again when you're
surrounded by people who you don't even
have to finish sentences for to know
that they understand you and your
intentions and what what you're trying
to create in the world you feel a deep
sense of of peace and comfort with that
many people today referred about as sort
of your tribe and how beautiful would it
be if we really had a connection with
all people what we felt that sense of
we're all part of this really grand
tribe and we we constantly are connected
to that and so that's what the resonance
here is meant to represent yeah we can
lift it up maybe today yeah let's do it
you can see
yeah that one's heart resonance
the red also reminds me of the heart
yeah yeah maybe look at some of the
other ones too let's do that to have
that warm feeling with everyone that is
a tribe you
I mean Ramdas had this quote imagine if
everyone was God and drag and when
you're sitting in a lift or doing
whatever you're doing going quickly
throughout your day and it's easy to
sort of just like not be paying
attention to people but when you have
that moment of presence with everyone
you interact with even if it's brief and
just feeling connected you can create
that and so it's it was always something
he said I really appreciated everyone
else imagine everyone has got and
dragged God and God in drag
Oh God in drag oh I didn't know you were
in death it's also that that quote is
also speaks heavily to everyone being in
their avatars or in their costumes and
then being able to kind of like switch
up your costumes or you're like yeah
avatars but like remembering that it's a
divine being there's a piece later that
I'm gonna say some words about that
we'll get to in a bit okay next is we
have images we have us via we've see
like we wish me luck with this this is a
spiritual material mm-hmm and yeah yeah
this is go ahead take take us take us
through this journey well what do you
what do you see and feel when you look
at this one Ron that one I see flower I
see
a bee's stinger oh I see the earthy
colors I like it I don't see my ex-wife
the colors of the bridesmaid dresses are
not a yeah this one yes I love you work
I don't you know my role is devil's
advocate so yeah yeah we're just talking
about server Harmon Harris on the show
was just mentioning that all right you
even before you talk to me about it
there was a meet like sitting on now
cushions for however many months it's
been of my life that I agree that it
makes it immediately jump that there was
like an essence of like a meditation
happening and then I didn't have enough
time I think to look at it before you
just were like one of the heads is like
super in the head and meditation and the
other one is melting into all that is
and I was like whoa that's cool yeah so
for this one in the middle you have two
people meditating and they're sitting
with their backs towards one another and
in the final piece actually which we'll
see in a second there's a white dot that
the larger head is staring at so the one
is really focused and just meditating
and becoming one with everything around
him or her and just feeling connected to
to the ether itself the other one as
they're meditating there had their ego
their self it's it's all about a
dialectic with how great they are for
meditating like what a good meditator
they are like how much people need to
know that they meditate right and so
that one is is sort of about these two
choices you have with spirituality like
for some people can be a very private
practice and it's very respectable for
other people they really want to share
that as a gift with others which is
really beautifully beautiful as well as
long as that that desire to receive that
as theirs is their but what we see a lot
a lot is that you so many people who
kind of missed the point and are
investing so much energy in their
spiritual quest by saying like oh look
how look how great I am a meditator girl
look how great I am at these different
practices rather than using them to feel
connected they're actually not and even
saying that like I've heard people say
things as oh I'm so much more not just
in you crazy yeah and I think we
especially see that a lot in in Silicon
Valley and what what that really says to
me is that they're they're using it as a
it's maybe coming from a place with fear
where they're not ready to truly connect
to things greater than themselves or
they really don't know how and so
they're using these practices to once
again replicate the version of
themselves that already exists and
that's what you see here whoa or even
augment it yeah yeah yeah the the we
were just a couple a couple days ago is
there it was very late and we were
assisting some of the garbage team with
the back and we were just assisting and
and afterward we were just talking about
how its what what matters is what you do
when no one's looking yeah so if you're
meditating for the purpose of your own
divine actualization and transcendence
versus to tweet about it afterwards
going to start telling the world so much
more not just blow it
I get it now yeah but yeah those acts of
kindness that type of stuff yeah Ron's
constantly giving young people or people
that are stop don't talk don't brag
about my kindness and generosity lie
tell um the miserable bastards like I am
here to be anyway help anyone let them
drown let's go to the next the next
image okay so there's a couple in this
around this this is a close up yes this
is just a close up to give you a better
sense of kind of the detailing at the
center of this piece it's quite a large
piece I actually don't remember the
dimensions but it's probably about three
times the size of this one
wider than this one and taller it's
probably three times the size wide Wow
yeah as you Joe mm-hmm okay and yeah and
the next one has the dot in it the [ __ ]
yeah so just to show that like rather
than trying to become one with source
the observation of source and
interaction with it becomes that
amplification so that's why I'm the one
side it's you sort of like dissolve into
the connection to source and on the
other side you're observing it like your
ego grows through that process yeah yeah
like stuff like that this is just a a
hat I did from the leftover paint from
that piece so okay yeah it's the Hat
yeah it's not a painting of a woman
wearing a head there is another painting
I don't have a larger photo behind me
that I'm covering out but yeah yeah so
I've just been making with after every
single piece with the leftover
ingredients a hat and you know give it
to someone who's done something recently
that I feel is like just really
connected to my heart love it
all right and then let's show will hey
hold on this one is a freedom yeah so
through this you can see by scale lets
me actually sniffing behind the bees
since you can see the size of of the
piece itself so this one's called
freedom and it's it's sort of a
nondescript being in a cloak and all the
woven parts of the being are once again
you have two themes of how they're being
amplified I think we all use our egos in
different way to proxy and maybe even
more so now that we live in a world
where we have so many channels for
communication more than ever but
communication itself is so compressed
that people are quite reserved in in
what they're actually saying and it's
diluted down to a quick text message or
a tweet and in that world like people
showed different parts of themselves in
different contexts and environments
quite easily and so there's very what
you often see is that the ego is proxy
even to the professional self like the
mother the daughter the brother the son
whatever it may be the basketball player
and that these identities for many
people have become almost like
self-contained I mean for me I've never
really shared with very many people that
I create artwork or much about my work
itself so it's in many ways a commentary
on that as well
and so what you see here is that's all
changed you see is the the shedding of
all the different ways the ego has been
proxied and sort of once again letting
the the self and the face that's
connecting forward with the world
connect to source and so it's becoming
more and more fierce and more that that
way sort of
color that is the the base for every
color or the base for no color and then
the the ego proxy I enjoyed that a lot
so then the little compressions of our
ego displayed as like little posts
across social platforms right now and we
take on the different ya personas
depending on how we feel maybe you yeah
and how does this then relate to the ego
proxy again yeah so the face is on the
the back that sort of like triangle
shape is a bunch of different phases
that are extending outward yeah and sort
of the shedding of all the different
egos that have been proxied before so
this part right here aha shedding of it
and then the up is towards so that's the
face that's are currently being
projected forward to the world and so in
this image it's it's actually in this
final state choosing to become connected
to source and more amorphous so through
the connection the the way the face
looks the shape of it matters less as
its as its sort of being projected into
the world its amorphous it turns into
that once again white color which to me
very much symbolizes source okay so it's
really yes the shed the ego proxies join
source join the source join the source
source be with you so happy these are
happening oh great great
okay all right excellence that's freedom
and then Nexus brain Falls I really
enjoyed this one too yeah so this one is
about weight oh yeah where do you over
does this one feel like oh yeah yeah I
want to hear it on What's it feel like
to me losing one's mind okay yeah I'm
losing myself on the
are getting rid of baggage mmm yeah so
it would mmm that's good how about the
egregious amount the the egregious
amount of noise that is now in our
civilization and how it is cluttering
our essence and how we so desperately
need to empty that noise so that we can
reconnect more deeply yeah so I mean
waterfalls are a beautiful thing and
maybe we can also embrace what here is
brain Falls things follow waterfalls ok
cool waterfalls and brain Falls yeah the
brain Falls having a beautiful thing
where it's just sort of like rippling
out like a steady stream you can say
here's all like if you're thinking of
your mind is something that can only
hold on to so many thoughts or if you
concentrate on certain thoughts they
become stronger and actually viscerally
becomes stronger so if you concentrate
on things like love like compassion
based meditation you focus on things
like love and as a result you feel
happier there's also psychological tests
that show that if you don't have if you
have a dummy arm next to you but in your
field of sight it looks like it's your
arm but it's a prosthetic and someone
hits it that you feel pain right and so
that's that's the way our mind works so
if we know our mind works this way how
do we weather it for being the best
possible mine and for positivity we have
to focus on the positive things and get
rid of all the things that no longer
serve us and do that cleanse like some
people do that they were daily
meditative practice some people do that
you know every so often through all
sorts of means there's many wisdom
traditions that people use
I mean Freud who in many ways
inadvertently invented modern capitalism
actually helped helped create also a
therapeutic context in which some people
choose to do that this also speaks very
deeply to the information technology era
that were in the exponential technology
era because the clutter has increased
the amount of humans propagating noise
has increased has the amount of humans
propagating signal why is it so buried
right now why is the truth being
obfuscated who is behind the obfuscation
of the truth we'll talk about that yeah
we're gonna actually let's talk about
that oh yeah let's talk about that now
what is behind the obfuscation of the
truth does it feel like there's
something at play on planet earth but
beyond the 3d physical reality so why is
it so hard to find what truth means
today and and is there something beyond
the 3d reality that is making it
difficult are we living in a 3d reality
what do you think what is the reality by
4d with time or 11d what is it I think
in actuality it's very hard I mean back
to even the simulation 38 question it's
very hard to to scientifically prove it
one way or another and so perhaps more
interesting is how do we as a society
decide what what truth means and I think
when people say we're in a post truth
the world I think we're in a
disconnected world I think we connected
everyone initially
Internet and not everyone there's many
people who were still not connected
technologically but we we connected a
large portion of humanity promising this
sort of you know idea that we would have
resonance and that greatness would come
from that collaboration when in
actuality the way information was ranked
and dispersed it made people feel like
polarizing views had greater weight than
they do much like a coalition government
and the result of this is having people
feel like they don't know how to find
the truth they don't know what is is
truth it's easy to spread misinformation
and when we think of how we construct
reality and how we construct truth what
is considered one person being crazy or
another person being in touch with
reality it's just the idea of consensus
among people that this is truly what
happened and this is truth and this is
reality and how do we create that
consensus in a technical era today I
think there's many people working on
that problem through different
verification protocols for understanding
the weight and the veracity and the
source of information I think we also
offline you know in our day to day world
are increasingly feel disconnected from
even our neighbors you know there was a
growing up like we knew who Oliver I
know who my neighbors were we I mean I
grew up in Minnesota but we often left
our doors unlocked and I can't imagine
doing that in San Francisco I don't know
who my neighbors are I know if you have
done in my building but on the block
very few and I think that's the
experience for for many people today
especially living in urban areas and so
when we think about what is truth what
is reality today I think we're we're
collectively deciding that it's okay for
our truth to be that we we don't know
one another and that were disconnected
and that
okay feeling like there's not one
certain truth or we want to complain
about it but we don't want to to work to
create a different reality yet and when
the true appetite is to create a
different reality because it becomes so
necessary for survival we well what do
you think
yeah the feel you yeah it resonates
deeply hearing you talk about the amount
of people that are that want to see a
big code update with the world and
putting in the hard work to make that
happen that's part of the grand game
that were in and the verification
protocols I think is an interesting way
what the decentralization technologies
are enabling us to do I think having
neologisms new words that speak to
things that are more spiritual and less
material is a good way to get us there
as well having more variations of the
word of love yeah all these types of
things huh okay and but but beyond the
planet are there forces at play on the
planet that are from beyond the planet
do I believe in aliens is that we're
going I think that so if we look at the
the genetic variation between like the
slide that's like difference in genetic
material and the great variance between
a human and a banana or like a human and
an ape and we decide that we're not
going to ever shift that upwards and
think that there would be great variance
in the other direction that seems quite
statistically improbable
so we go point whatever 5% more than our
last iteration and then we're supposed
to have variation that that's the well
in general there's with a very small
small difference in the composition of
DNA you have these tremendous
differences and things from like between
like humans in a banana or humans in an
ape but that's like one that's 50%
homology with the banana and like 99.5
or more with ya and so think about so
when you when you look at the difference
between us and apes is it not
presumptuous to think that there's
nothing shifted upwards in variants so
there's nothing unique meaning there's
nothing that has variants shifted in the
other direction my points are 1%
difference between humans and something
else that is more intelligent or
involved or exist in some other way like
or that difficulty other perception
vehicles that exist on the planet that
humans are not endowed with yeah I think
you can also I mean there's different
ways to look at the question I think we
could also look at what other types of
intelligence exists on earth like octopi
so if there's a book called other minds
it toxic okay so it talks about but yes
teachers well yeah so other minds is a
really interesting read that talks about
how different forms of consciousness
have evolved and one of the forms they
talk about is octopi and how they're
highly intelligent and that they have a
very evolved form of consciousness and
that there's actually a lot about their
minds we really don't understand but
there's reason to believe that they have
in many ways intelligence that could be
far superior to our own and we've
actually recently had I've seen
increasing coverage warning people from
places like the World Economic Forum not
to eat octopi because I quit
because of how smart they are and also
the Canberra JH declaration on
consciousness when it is so applauded
yeah oh great yeah so it explicitly
stated that octopi feel and our
conscious and so therefore we should not
eat them and there's there's
consequences to eating them I mean I
think I choked with you once about like
octopi Lera T like yeah yeah yeah we're
so afraid about singularity but like the
octopi are good no more yeah the moment
has come when they dominate the land
yeah they were like we were peaceful
weird rockets survived yeah interesting
okay so then out of all the tiny blip of
perception that we have that there's so
much more that even octopi dolphins any
other sort of mass clumps of fungi or
redwood forests the way that they
communicate their perception strategies
of communication strategies are just in
many ways can be superior to ours okay
all right yes phones are not that smart
yeah yeah yeah well it's interesting
there's still more to unpack about
what's actually happening on planet
Earth with you but maybe we can maybe
we'll end up getting to that do you
think there's a global ruling elite I
think there's definitely concentrations
of power among different groups of
people I think it's hard to deny that
today we're gonna get in trouble
[Music]
you're gonna come after it
should one endeavor to join the
depends on what your goals are I mean if
we're talking about it moving to a
collaborative context for a better you
know cultural paradigm that might be
best fit for the survival of humanity
then that would fall more into that the
Dominator paradigm and so it depends
what vision you want to see exist and
which one you're trying to be hmm behind
he could it be that one could endeavor
in and help transition the triangle to
the circle and help update the codes
without or in a way that is with the
current dominators you know I think a
friend of mine put it best when he once
said there was like a group of people I
was sort of naturally shifting away just
like they were in a room and I felt that
they represented values and things that
I did not and so I just naturally
shifted away and he calmed down he's
like you do this without even realizing
it like when people you know you don't
even always know beforehand but when
they represent these things that don't
feel line with you you naturally seems
like gravitate away from that yeah
what's wrong with that yeah so yeah so
and he sort of just looked at me for a
minute and said they need us to
they who are they who are you and what
are you doing here what did you do with
the monkeys it's so on a bell curve of
let's say spiritual actualization and
connectedness Intertek miss that if you
are closer to the end where you are
really melted into all that is maybe
your role is to identify people that are
almost done with their pull up into the
field and help them but if you go to
people at the other tail of the bell
curve or that are still in the middle it
can be really difficult
it'll be like moving a brick wall so
there's there's I think some nuance
there but I like that that point also
you can do cool things like make art
like this that then catalyzes people in
positions of power to feel more
spiritually awakened and interconnected
I like that but who controls the global
ruling elite okay I know Nagi seemed to
be interviewing all these really smart
people and bringing them together from
different different backgrounds I
thought you had something to do with it
no she's blowing our cover
we were in trouble okay let's go to the
self portrait that's the next one mm-hmm
yes there's a lot to say about this one
who and I've spoken about this on the
show before actually I don't think Ron
and what do you think about this one
yeah
I have nothing it reminds me of a
mannequin upside down with no head and
then it is it's got no head that's his
bum and he's on a platform upside down
that's you can't fool me yeah what are
you Alan well I think that there was
something to me that called me towards
feeling about it the way that you were
describing it to me because you know I
especially have had a pretty good amount
of mentors in my life recently that if
and and just divine connection to the
source has also catalyzed this in me but
to see humans as other divine beings
period and there is something that's
potentially coming through humans that
are acting as channels that are that are
acting and maybe partially malevolent or
partially benevolent ways and so this is
not necessarily to always go with the
sources because there could be something
that if someone is trying to potentially
harm you or most people are good I also
I'm just I'm especially for men is to
treat women like they are divine beings
and to make that something that is more
of our essence I am not perfect I still
have a proclivity to occasionally look
in a way that is not Hart centric first
and not divine being first and then I
catch myself and change myself to feel
that way about it and I immediately feel
better and the same issue happens with
with pornography or other behavioral
mechanisms that were not even aware of
that then trained us to objectify
further and to not respect the divinity
within women and I actually the most
divine men I know are the ones that know
how to co-create with women
the peak of creative potential so yeah
give us yo the thoughts on this yeah so
this one is titled self-portrait and
it's about the feelings of being viewed
through your gender and that being
something that instead of so many of us
instead of feeling something that
recognizes your beauty as a human
instead objectifies you and sees you
just as just as a body to be objectified
and so and this in this sort of extreme
interpretation of that feeling you can
see the woman is it's her back to the
viewer her hand like her arms are cross
in front of her with her hand over her
back shoulder so it's a very sort of
like guarded position her head's been
cut off so she can't speak and her legs
are you know caught in this cement block
and so she really has no mobility to and
so it's really just that feeling that I
think many many people not just women
can relate to which is that that feeling
when someone it's the opposite of
feeling you know compassion and
connection to people when they look at
someone or treat them like you're just
an object and you're voiceless and you
don't have freedom of movement and
you're just this thing that I'm viewing
as whatever it means to me to transact
across
these are very thought-provoking yeah in
in see this is completely different than
the spiritual material heart resonance
for you actually maybe there's some
synergy to the freedom but I feel like
that these that these teach completely
different ways of there's there's a
similarity of that spiritual awakening
but yeah so with this one I think part
of the larger discussion is how do you
sorry yes go to the next my dad if we're
talking about a Dominator versus a
collaborative context if we're still in
a paradigm where based on gender were
objectifying people or there's other
reasons that people are objectified but
let's say for doing that based on gender
and we can't co-create yeah between our
across genders it's also highly highly
problematic and so this represents a
vision of a complementary piece I'm
working on of like what it looks like to
when there's just total freedom of
expression yeah and you're seeing
freedom of expression and you're just
seeing completely as whatever the beauty
is you're supposed to create in the
world and you're seeing for that first
yeah and so this is a piece of actually
I'm working on right now that I have not
finished but this one's called whomp
womb kind womb kind yeah I love the
colors of what is the one of the most
sacred if not the most sacred space
which is the womb mm-hm
yeah yeah to come from that
the book especially men not having to
carry children within them and grow them
for nine months yeah yeah yeah yeah that
for men to connect deeper to that
feeling I think is very important and
coming from that creation from their
mother yeah yeah so this one is all
about our interconnectedness as humans
we all have come from a womb and so
you're exactly right it's the the colors
that represent this it also shows sort
of the way these these women and faces
are turned towards each other and
they're connecting with one another but
then you also have the layered faces and
when you actually turn this piece and
rotate it in another direction it's the
minds are connected through the thoughts
of the other woman's it's sort of the
layered Wow I can't believe I just
pulled that off so so quickly -
interesting so this is another way to
view it and and this one the the minds
that gave birth to them are still
influencing them that's their oh their
mental connection whoa yeah nice
now I okay I'm following I'm falling so
there will be a symmetry then of what we
see on the right now with what will
potentially be on dog on the left yeah
so it's less about the symmetry itself
it's more that this is a face and this
is a face yes yeah yes yes yes I meant
with the other pieces that are not yet
yeah the left yeah okay okay
so as though what comes out of the womb
is then also affecting within the place
of creation that they came from just
like them oh yeah all of our minds are
connected in the same
way that our existence is and so you see
that like these other faces are
resonating with thoughts that were
created by the women the minds that gave
birth to them okay and then we have
heart arrhythmia is next which is
actually the the one that I was
initially commenting on that I said was
like nerve endings of God yeah and that
its flipped here okay so you get quite
an interesting point
so is it isn't this a cute cool view oh
I see yeah it's cool cuz when you view
the art this way almost something a
little bit different yeah comes at how
does this one make you feel there was
something a little bit more hierarchical
and less header ARCIC all about it about
this one when it was flipped on its side
okay because then it almost looked like
there was a Dominator hmm in that sense
yeah yeah yeah but here it looks much
more head Oracle decentralized but also
oh you oh I also see you you start with
deeper shades you start with the deeper
colors darker colors in that in the in
the center of the centers on this one on
heart arrhythmia but then on on heart
resonance is this one's it goes down it
goes darker gradient as it goes down so
these are lighter in the centers it's
fluid interesting yeah okay it's all
fluid yeah so this is the one that you
described as people are they really for
you your describe it as being inspiring
because it reminded you that people are
almost like the nerve endings of source
or your God
yes and so all of their emotions and
their being is is connected to that and
that you can see and feel that here so
these are sister paintings and her
resonance is supposed to be both of them
have these dots that are these focal
points that draw the eye on when you're
viewing the painting to to study your
focus because if you stir this long
enough it looks like it's moving it's so
busy and chaotic and you need your eye
to retreat to a certain focal point so
you feel study and it becomes less
dizzying and the degree to which it's
dizzying is amplified when everyone's
kind of like in a different different
resonance they're not beating together
to the same sort of the same sort of
drum they're not in resonance they're
not in vibration with one another and
all of that movement is quite chaotic
and you're like looking for the dot
almost there's a place of retreat from
it and it's not a bad thing but it's
arrhythmia in terms of the heart's not
in sync and beating together everyone's
doing their own thing
they're not collaborating this would be
more the dominator paradigm and this
other one Hart residence is that feeling
that there are these points of retreat
visually for the eye and you can Center
on them but your your your focus isn't
shifted you to do that as sharply as
quickly because of the lack of the lack
of movement that is not in residence so
in this all of the phases are equally
distance apart they're all the same
outline whereas these are different
phases yeah those that yes some of the
roses are different the lips are
different
yeah the head shapes are different yeah
yeah oh these are this and these are the
C and those are uniform these are
uniform interesting there's some that
are making out on okay and then and the
next one is this watercolor sketch you
can she please explain to us your
process of making the art yeah so for
the painting reviewed earlier called
freedom this is the watercolor and
sketch I did prior to to map out what I
was going to do and so usually I won't
always use watercolors but usually I'll
kind of map out and draw out what what I
want to put on the canvas and so for
this one I started playing with these
gradients of blue and I didn't even know
what I was trying to say at first when I
was drawing it and I often feel this way
with with art and creating it it's like
I create these these drawings are these
images and it's just like flowing out of
me of these ways that I feel and I'm
thinking about things and don't yet
quite know how to digest them with words
yes and then often I look at it and like
start laughing or sometimes feel sacks
I'm like oh that's what that's what I'm
digesting that's what this feels like it
means and then I'll spend you know the
the weeks or months that it takes to
paint it too digesting and meditating
sort of on that subject and how that
feels in an often also curates what I
start reading about our diving more
deeply into
I realize that my mind feels the need to
digest that more and learn more about it
yeah
you're my heart too I try to keep them
connected yes yes and then is this then
so once you start this process of kind
of of channeling what is what is cooking
up within you through you onto on tart
is this usually sketched and then
watercolor is that usually the process
before you take it to canvas usually
it's a few of them like the
self-portrait and brain follows I didn't
sketch or anything first I just went
straight to the canvas to start painting
them for for these ones and so for heart
resonance and heart arrhythmia and
spiritual material and freedom all of
those I sketched first and used
watercolors first to get a sense for
them yeah boom kind no that was another
one way I just went straight to the
canvas yeah just started painting this
also speaks to me the heart residence
and heart arrhythmia speak to me about
the about the interconnectedness of all
of us independent of the variable of art
of the skin color yeah the one that
speaks to me about and then okay what
about is let's let's jump to is
consciousness localized in our nervous
system does it come from beyond this
vehicle that we reside in what are your
thoughts on that I mean our mind I I
think of Moore's like a TV right so we
think of many people think of their
minds as consciousness is the same thing
mapped onto one another whereas really
our mind is just a TV taking in inputs
from all of the the data points and
sensory stimulation
around us and in really the entire world
to project images and the more we put
ourselves in proximity to certain images
the more that's what we see and think of
as reality in the world and so there's
there's power in viewing reality in such
a way because you realize that that
nothing is permanent and that you can
actually shift the things that you're
consuming or thinking about or seeing to
play different things on the TV channel
or in your mind and so you know there's
people call it like super hippie dippie
or woowoo to say things like how such a
good vibes good vibrations only but
really in terms of like resonance theory
like that it actually like
scientifically makes more and more sense
and it is important that things were
we're digesting especially in an age
where there seems to be endless access
to information yeah varying qualities of
maybe truth to it but the access point
is there and you can digest endlessly
and so how do we make sure we're getting
rid of things if we have too much in our
mind or how do we make sure that we're
focusing on things that we want to
comprise our consciousness people
probably do a really good job on the
show of taking the questions that I ask
them and then answering it in the way
that they want to answer it fantastic
answer so addressing the core part of it
is like I'll address another part that I
think is very interesting but that's a
that's a really good way to put it to be
vigilant of the inputs we take in and
also that we can then potentially even
tune into other channels I can tune in
to your channel or on channel I can tune
in to an animals channel the collective
consciousness is channel can you really
do a good job at continuing to tap into
those that are seemingly different from
you but that can you get there can you
can you do that to feel the
the different channels of source another
good way to put it is if you are running
a simulation or if you are and another
species can you potentially tune into
what the human experiment is doing
between the channels of the humans or
between the channels of the from behind
their eyes like that okay we already
talked about this a little bit earlier
what are we gonna do with the future of
the way that we treat things with a
value hmm it doesn't seem like GDP cares
much about human wellbeing or or
creativity if if like if basically if
you took this piece of art around heart
resonance and you said things and you
and nobody in the world cared about it
yeah and then we'd be like there's no
value in it or infinite value so in
terms of sort of the way we're shifting
understandings of value I think it's
important to route them and like well
what is value what is reality we talked
about earlier which is just consensus
that something is true when something
exists so by extension one manifestation
of our collective consciousness would be
the reality is that we agree or agree on
in terms of governance and right now we
have people who are at the cutting edge
if we talk about governance in terms of
monetary policy or in terms of how we
transact or store or understand value
we're working on things like distributed
ledger technology and blockchain and
crypto and especially in Silicon Valley
we hear about these so often and in many
ways it's overhyped and in many ways
it's not we're just at the very
beginning of what these technologies can
do I think when you're talking about you
know Dominator versus collaborator
cultural contacts or financial context
what's very promising about the
innovations for for not all but many of
these new let's say system designs for
for money or for stories of value is
that within them you can create smart
contracts or you can create not on all
of them but in many of them like
aetherium you can create smart contracts
which allow us to you can think of it in
one way embed cultural values or social
values or even a social welfare system
perhaps into a monetary system or a
governance system of value we come from
source in many ways to not participate
in the social political economic
machinery we come to connect back to
source and to experience life at its
fullest and I don't think the social
political economic machinery does any of
that I think it's a big machine that
sucks the beautiful planet in and churns
it out into [ __ ]
that is super unnecessary what are you
doing about it
Bank yeah so just some thoughts yeah
yeah yeah but you know bitching about it
yes it's not it's not it's it's
conversation about it and then do
something about it then well I think
well wouldn't we are slowly things we
can do I mean one thing you can do is
raise awareness about that that you know
this most of the world most of
consciousness most of gravity is just a
bunch of stories it's a bunch of stories
that we're telling ourselves and we're
telling each other and we're passing on
generation to generation maybe we're
even epigenetically encoding within
ourselves to create survival traits and
you know out of tinfinity amongst our
offspring but amongst all of these
stories one we can start shifting is
that you don't need to dominate to
survive that you can collaborate you
don't need to have climb up a corporate
ladder necessarily and look for fame or
look for self-love or look for happiness
or look for tons of money there sure
maybe you'll find fame maybe you'll find
money but if ultimately you're looking
for love and happiness and you get to
the top and you look down and like why
don't I still feel this where are those
things if they weren't here you see this
this narrative play out again and again
especially in Silicon Valley where I
think a lot of creation not all but a
lot is fear-based people feeling like
they need to prove themselves they need
to create something for the sake of of
proving that they're valuable when
really what they're saying is that they
don't love themselves yet because if
they did they'd realize they're already
are valuable
everyone's valuable or that they think
that they need to you know people in our
our current system oftentimes think they
need to accumulate capital to prove that
there were something and then you find
that a lot of the wealthiest people are
some of the most unhappy and so really
where does this feeling of joy and love
come from if not from that and I think
we can educate people about that I think
we have power to do things and the
consumer choices we make I mean we can
choose to consume a bunch of things
because we're buying into this story
that if you have been latest iPhone or
the nicest car or you live in a flashy
apartment that people will respect you
and what your friend and that you'll be
valuable but if we choose to look at
those choices and say oh well those
actually make me feel or be those things
does that embody the person I want to be
in my values if we if we become more
critical in that sense and encourage
others to then I think we're doing
something
with every choice we make yeah your
point out stories this is massive I love
that what's the most beautiful thing in
the world
love a little bit more yeah I mean
Einstein wrote this beautiful letter to
his daughter I don't know if you've ever
read it it was recently given to the the
archives at the Hebrew University in
Jerusalem and it's a letter in which he
describes a sense that the world is not
really ready to hear about the most
powerful energetic source known to
humanity and that it's the only thing
that has that man won't be able to
control that has the ability to produce
infinite light and energy and that is
always replenishable and that this thing
is love and he actually talks in this
letter about how love fits into all of
his different theories and that it's so
important that his his daughter
recognizes that this is the most
powerful energy source in the entire
world and so I think we have an
opportunity at every moment to tap into
that to tap into feeling love for
ourselves just happen the feeling love
for others love for for art love for
whatever strikes a creative chord for us
a collaborative chord Chinese food my
beer for Chinese food that love is
creation and that love can also be seen
as hydrogen and oxygen coming together
to form it it's not just love that's
creation get over them the universe is
very violent don't you know anything
about tough love it's not you know don't
be be careful you'll get burned
and maybe you get burned in that you
have to keep saying like I'll get burned
a little bit here and there to live a
life when we're mindless zombies dancing
around the Maypole in an ignorant bliss
for the working for the alien with big
eyes gray skin and we all look like it
may be or it might be that yeah they
could take it might be that we feel
closer and closer to people around us if
we choose to even though some people
show us their they don't have that maybe
they've learned not to trust or maybe
they've been shown that they can get
burned but instead of treating everyone
in the world like they're gonna burn
them or that they deserve distrust to
give them that chance because I mean do
you want to leave a world where you're
closed off from people and you can't
trust them and you don't know who your
neighbors are and you're you're rooted
in fear or do you want to get burned
every so often but always assume the
best and and choose to be rooted in love
let's get there together let's build
that future yeah Samantha thank you so
much for coming on the show thank you
for having me yeah it's good to be here
thank you so happy we finally made it
hopefully hopefully for more of these
epic conversations as also the art
progresses yeah it will be very fun to
continue coming and talking about it wow
so many cool topics covered thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let's know what you're thinking
also do check out the links in the bio
and go and follow Samantha across
Instagram Twitter her website go and
check that out have more conversations
to your friends your families
congresspeople online about spiritual
art and about spiritual awakening
through art have more conversations
about it also shout-out to Ron Vargas
for producing and directing thank you
very much Ron and also support the
artists entrepreneurs the organization's
the spiritual leaders around the world
that you believe and support them
support simulation help us continue
growing the show and prospering you can
find our patient
cryptocurrency PayPal links in the
bottom below design cool merchants get
paid that's down there as well and go
and build the future manifest your
dreams into the world thank you very
much for tuning in we'll see you soon
peace
[Music]